can we contain kovat 19 without locking
down the economy this is a question and
I do care about this article because
Shai shalosh warts is one of the bigger
names in machine learning theory so it
was interesting for me to see what he
and his collaborator here had to say
about the kind of outbreak and the
strategy to contain it so contain maybe
isn't the right word made that they
asked I think the way that they asked
the question is how are we going to
survive this the best and so this in no
means is an endorsement by me I'm not a
medical professional please just view
this as a commentary and an explanation
of what they are saying I'll give my my
opinions along the way of course
so they identify three different models
for handling the spread of : 19 and
we'll start with the third one because
they argue for the first one and this
builds more suspense so they say there
is countrywide lockdown
right until the spread of the virus is
under control they say could take
anywhere from weeks to months it is the
safest route but it does not prevent a
second wave from occurring now of course
if you have people let's say these are
people right then the thing is everyone
just stays in their stay in your house
right everybody right until it's it's
kind of gone now they say correctly
there's a risk of a second wave because
only a single infected person because
there's no immunity still has the
potential of creating creating another
epicenter so they they don't consider
this option
next option is called containment based
selective quarantine which means find
all the positive cases and put them in
quarantine so let's say we go here and
you know we let you roam around freely
but we know we can test people and we
know that some of them are positive so
we simply tell them to stay at home
right now this depends a lot on how well
you can test people or and it also
depends on what they claim the
contagious time interval we know that
there are people that are contagious
without showing symptoms so unless you
can test every single person all the
time this is likely to not really help a
lot now there is various data from
various countries that actually shows it
can reduce the load but they basically
argue against that because there are
these contagious people and you can
never test fast enough or accurate or
thoroughly enough and then they say
there is risk based based selective
quarantined which means what it means
that so some of these people are going
to be at risk and in this case we
obviously mean old people so old people
and I draw them with a cane not because
all people aren't fit just because they
have better tastes in canes so and then
there are young people and they run a
smartphone with tik-tok and what we are
going to say is that you youngsters
you're not really at risk from this so
you go out you sneeze on each other you
go about your life normally and you old
people basically stay at home until all
the young people have immunity so we
ramped up the cases and then it flattens
out eventually
in the low-risk population and at that
point there is enough herd immunity
right all these people are now immune so
that the the old person here even if
they now go out again they won't catch
it because everyone's already had it
so they argue for this particular
strategy and or at least they analyze
this particular strategy now I have to
say at the beginning that the core
assumption here is that this quarantine
of the high-risk people you can do
basically in a perfect way
so the assumption here is that you are
able to perfectly quarantine all the
high-risk people and that's the level of
infection in the low-risk population has
no influence on the level of infection
in the high-risk population and in my
opinion I simply don't believe that I
simply don't believe you can build this
quarantine I think even these old people
they need food sometimes the nursing
home need staff so even they even if
they can reduce their contact to the
outside world they cannot fully be
sheltered and that means the more
infections you have in the low-risk
population the more infections you will
have in the high-risk population so I
think the fundamental core assumption of
this model is quite flawed that being
said let's analyze it so we assume that
all the high-risk people none of them is
going to get sick because they all stay
at home so the math in this paper is
actually pretty basic so we'll go
through it a bit more more detailed so
we'll understand the core argument so
they introduce the following quantities
M here M is the low-risk population
right this is the population size
viii or new let's call it new new here
is the probability so that's the
probability that if you are sick you
need to go to the ICU right so sick
means simply you have the virus and ICU
means that it's the symptoms are so bad
that you need help from the medical
system in order to overcome the disease
right so if we multiply so if you
multiply the population size by the
probability that if you get sick you
need to go to the IC what do we get we
get a worst case scenario so the
basically the authors here and I find
this this is the good part of this
analysis they really they don't rely on
kind of pandemic dynamics epidemiology
exponential growth and so on
they simply consider the worst case so
MD here if you multiply these two
numbers what does that mean that is the
number of severe cases severe meaning
you need ICU cases if everybody gets
sick if all get sick if everybody gets
sick at the same time right same time so
this is the work so let's say we all go
out the lowest population and we all
sneeze in each other's faces as much as
we can and we just all get sick at the
same time then this here is the number
of people going to the ICU right and if
this so they introduced this quantity B
here B is the number of beds in the ICU
if the number of beds in the ICU is
larger
then the worst case severe cases right
then we are safe so that's the argument
basically it's not that we are safe it
is no one will die from lack of an ICU
bed right which which is kind of the
lever we have as a population if you
assume everyone's gonna get sick anyway
and so on so if the number of beds is
larger than the worst case number of ICU
patients we are safe that's at least how
they define safe all right so that's
their premise now what what are they
going to do they're going to find a
quantity where they can bound this this
thing so they're going to find a bound
and upper bound on the number of severe
cases and if this upper bound is lower
than the number of beds then they can
they can say with we're safe with this
method say they said see see this is a
worst-case analysis under their
assumptions all right so I said they
don't resort to any kind of
epidemiological dynamics they simply
estimate this thing from current numbers
then introduce two more quantities here
P star and K now K is the current number
of severe cases right so this is kind of
an an analogue to this thing here so
these two are connected this is the
current number of severe cases and this
up here is the total possible like the
worst case number of severe cases in the
future
likewise P star here is the percentage
of people the percent of people that are
sick right
and they claim correctly this is unknown
so if we could test everybody who is
sick not severe just sick and up here
this has no connection because of course
you can imagine here another factor
times let's call this P P plus or
something which is the number of people
who are sick in the worst case which of
course in our worst case scenario is one
so that's why they don't include it here
so this is the current percentage of
sick people so this here is a is a
percentage and this here is an actual
number keep that in mind
alright now if we do some basic
reformulations here if we take this P
star and multiply that by you see than
the in this corner here multiply it by
the total size of the population right
we get the number of people who are
currently sick sick right is the
percentage of current sequence this is
the total size of a population to get
the number of people who are currently
sick if we take that in the denominator
and put K here which is the number of
people who are currently severe then we
get an estimate of this quantity new so
remember what new is new is the
probability if you are sick you go to
the ICU
that's all the ICU means your severe
right so these are the current number of
sick people and these are the current
number of severe people this gives you
an estimate of if you are sick right
what's the probability that your severe
now they argue that this number it
doesn't change it independent
so that this this quantity here is a
constant so the probability that if you
are sick from this virus you go to the
ICU doesn't change over time so we can
estimate it with current numbers right
which is a pretty you know a reasonable
thing to assume that this stays constant
unless the virus mutates or something so
we know the total size of the population
we know the current number of severe
cases you can make an argument about
that so do we really know the current
number of severe cases because there's
an exponential growth involved this
might be difficult to estimate and they
say the same thing so they say this is
the only time where they reference the
dynamics of the situation it grows at an
exponential rate so what we can do is we
can take a worst-case upper bound they
say to be on the safe side perform a
worst-case analysis so they instead of
taking K they add this confidence
interval on it that is based on
concentration inequalities so they don't
use K they use this K tilde here which
has two additional summons here that is
supposed to be an upper bound with
confidence at least at least one over
Delta here and this you can set for
example to be 0.05 that gives you a 95%
sorry a 95% confidence that this is a
upper bound on that now this comes from
some concentration found and there are
certain assumptions behind this upper
bound here which I don't know enough
about to critique them here I'm going to
assume they're reasonable if they are
not then of course that is an additional
point of criticism of this work
all right so instead of using K here we
are saying we're on the safe side and we
use this K tilde so we know this as well
now the unknown quantity of course is
this thing here P star what is the
percentage of people that are currently
sick right yeah so that the goal is now
to find to find that so they say okay if
we plug in this upper bound of K tilde
then with this this probability we can
upper bound this quantity nu which is
exactly you know what we wanted because
we need to upper bound MD that's what
they say here so since at the top we saw
that M times nu equals MD and we want to
upper bound MD so we can rearrange this
thing this if we plug in these two
together we see that the M cancels out
and we can upper bound MD by this
quantity here the upper bound on the
current severe cases divided by the
percentage of the current by the
percentage of the currently sick people
so again they're reformulate and they
plug in they this of course needs to be
smaller than the number beds so they
plug this in here and they say now what
we have to do to see is if this quantity
is larger than this quantity of two
quantities we know then we are safe now
again our goal is going to be to find a
quantity that lower bounds P star but up
but is larger than this quantity here
and they do this via hypothesis testing
they call this quantity here they call
it
he tilde and they do a hypothesis test
for classic statistics where they ask is
P star significantly larger than P tilde
if that's the case then we're safe if
not we're not and how do they do that
they say okay we have the population
right I did draw this at one point let's
go back there we have the population
here right and what we can do is we can
just go out and uniformly uniformly test
people I just randomly select people
know this is an old person though people
stay at home so we randomly select
people to test and their test results
come back and this one this one's
healthy this one's healthy
this one's healthy this one's not
healthy right and so we have four tests
and out of the four one was positive can
we work out a hypothesis test from that
so can we decide whether P star is
probably much larger than P tilde or not
and the answer is yes because this is a
uniform sample you can work out using
classic statistical tools whether or not
you can reject a null hypothesis or not
and they actually work this out and they
they do give a number here and that's
this so they say if we test n which is
for let's say four and a half times this
quantity B divided by K so the number of
beds divided by the upper bound on the
current severe cases so we test for
point five times this many people right
then if we find at least ten positive
cases or more then with a probability of
95%
we know that the risk based model is
safe right so the more of course the
more infected people you find in this
case the better because that means
because the number of severe cases stays
constant at any given time
it means that a lot more people are
infected that means the probability that
you were going to become severe is lower
that way that's why it says at least so
again you go out you test n people and
according to this formula plug in the
numbers here for your current situation
if you find at least 10 people then with
the probability of at least 95% you know
that this model is safe cool and this is
done using you know classic statistical
testing hypothesis testing literature so
I think that is a pretty cool result but
I do severely criticized the underlying
assumption which is that you can
perfectly enforce this quarantine of
course if you can't it means that there
is a direct correlation between the
number of sick people in your low-risk
population the number of sick people in
your high-risk population which means
that more of the high-risk population
are going to get infected as well which
again means that your number B of ICU
beds is going to drop severely because
they have a higher hospitalization rate
which makes your entire model that we
developed down there less valid because
now this used to be a constant in the
model it's now no longer a constant it's
sinking and the worse it gets the more
it's sinking and yes so that that may
make what you initially thought was a
safe model into a very non safe model
very quickly and that doesn't include
all the high risk people that are going
to be in danger additionally because you
can't enforce the quarantine all right
so this was my take on that take it for
what it's worth
and I wish you a healthy pandemic
bye-bye